hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast scalable lab automation
to open platforms from Peco leader to
high-throughput technologies presented
by hell Laurinburg head of product
management at econ and manuel bower
marketing manager at econ i'm susie
valdez of lab roots and i will be your
moderator for today's event we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laborat so
leading scientific social networking
websites and also sponsored by T cons T
Khan is a leading global provider of
automated laboratory instruments and
solutions to learn more about T cons
visit WWE can calm before we begin I'd
like to remind everyone that this
presentation is interactive we want to
hear from you so questions comments can
be submitted via as a green Q&A button
at the lower left of your screen once or
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of our presentation also you are
viewing this presentation in a slide
window to enlarge the window click on
the icon in the lower right hand corner
of the slide window if you cannot hear
or see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right or the Q&A button and
let us know that you're having a problem
I will now turn our presentation over to
these fine gentlemen how Laurinburg and
Manuel Bauer welcome gentlemen
thank you for the nice introduction my
name is mano power I have to start and
I'll be talking about our D 300 our
digital dispenser and during the
presentation I'll tell you what digital
dispensing means and how it can help you
to enhance your workflows so I'll start
off with an introduction what digital
dispensing is then how digital spending
can help you solve challenges with low
volume dispensing and essay
miniaturization and how the d 300 e
digital Spencer can help you with that
and then walk you through some example
data and then the software wizards and
end with a summary before then hand over
to health for the second part of the
presentation so the d 300 e is a small
desktop instrument a dispenser which
allows you to spend le veau any volume
into any will in any essay played
quickly easily and automatically you
just have to add your liquid to the
dispenser and let the instrument to the
rest so the applications we see for the
d 300 is in proteomics then also in
biomolecule drug discovery in genomics
for miniaturized qPCR set up in
entomology also in small molecule drug
discovery and many others as you'll see
later on so the technology behind the DS
reality is based on the thermal inkjet
technology from Hewlett Packard so
you'll attacker has led the development
of inkjet technology for the past 20
years and what they do is they reliably
dispense piccoli the droplets of ink in
printers billions of times per day what
the d300 email does it it uses this
material proof technology and applies it
now for life science research
so here you can see the the dispenser on
the upper right hand corner and then on
the right side you see the dispensed 8
cassettes we have key 8 plus cassettes
for smaller volumes so the smallest one
is 11 Pico leaders and then the d4 plus
cassettes for higher volumes I'm
especially if you want to do than
normalizations or backfields with your
solvent here you just see a enlargement
of a dispenser so in this tiny little
cup and let me highlight that for you in
in this tiny little cup you will put
your fluid in and then is the bottom
view and from these non-visible 22
dispenser nozzles the fluid will then be
dispensed into the plate underneath as
you can see and if I now move to the
next video the next slide you can see
here this is just an enlarged view of
the dispenser models and you can see a
tiny drop just dispensed from there from
from the dispense head now how are these
volumes built up so why is it digital
dispensing because we have a certain
amount of fluid that we can dispense Oh
in that case you will see two tiny
droplets of 20 PQ liters each so this
makes up for the piccoli the same volume
here and for the 320 PQ leaders this
means 16 droplets of 20 PQ leaders and
so on and you can go up to sec here 5
microliters or up to 10 microliters of
dispense volume with the d 300 e now if
we look at this one there is a small
video going to play that shows how the
work flow is with the d 300 e so how the
fluid is put into the dispenser and then
how the dispensing is subsequently
happening into the SI plate underneath
it so if you could please play the video
you
as you could see if the dispense head
which is used is highlighted by a blue
light so that it easy to find and easy
to know where to put your fluid in so
where are the application areas you see
it so in proteomics of biomolecule
discovery and you can use it to do those
response curves preparation to evaluate
new biologics for example in genomics
you can use it for SI setup qPCR setup
and to dispense the masa mix in nucleic
acids and in entomology where you can
independently titrate enzyme substrates
and inhibitors and the the biggest
application area small molecule drug to
drug discovery bead at me or mass spec
to add and calibration standards in cell
based assays to do those response
experiments right in your si plate or in
biochemical assays to also do your adult
response set up right in the SI played
or another biochemist is wherever there
is low volume dispensing of compounds
and in for example synergy experiments
and we also have applications in
cosmetics where this way to use for
those responses up for active setting so
the different helps you to eliminate
existing challenges with repetitive
manual pipetting additional hydration
methods especially as it eliminates
time-consuming and costly labor and also
in process which eliminates process
related problems like delays and the
personal handle was which are required
and they substantial waste of precious
samples and up to 95% of cell later on
show and plates disposable tips luhan's
also complexity so therefore a high
level of expertise required and there's
also industry-wide standardization
limitations and repetitive stress
injuries with laboratory personnel so
how is this now avoided you see that the
titration planning and i'll walk you
through the software will it Wizards
later on and can be much reduced time
used for that and also the compound
iteration as you do
not have to do a serial dilution anymore
because you can just dispense the
required concentration into right into
the well of your si play so what are the
risks that come with challenging
pipetting parents so it can be pipetting
errors carryover errors or edge effects
in the plate and I'll talk later on how
we can reduce these also in flexibility
there is a trade-off between
scientifically desired versus convenient
to process also oftentimes their
specific dose is required and drug drug
interactions are very difficult to
pipette by hand then also the layout
often depends on the pipetting device
what you're able to achieve with that
and complex SI profiles are difficult to
set up manually everybody who ever
pipetted a synergy SI PI and can
certainly appreciate that and often
times there's no instant scheduling or
so the availability of personal
instrumentation so if you look at an
example workflow on how the d300 you can
help to streamline a manual process if
you look at how a classical titration
experiment or dose response expand would
be done is you start with your SI set up
where you have to do your drug
formatting your plate prep the diluent
addition your serial resolution then you
tape untape because you have to shake or
spin down and then probably have to do
an immediate dilution in media or ma
crease buffer you have to do by a
daughter replicate and then finally they
can arrive at your riot by your essay
with your titration series all these
steps in the middle of the glue step
they can actually be combined into one
by using the g300 ii by dispensing your
disposer sponsor of dose response curve
right into your si plate so how does it
compare to manual or even automated
pipetting and so what we have plotted
here are the IC 50s that have been
either dispensed by the d 300 on the
upward axis or manually or on the right
side here again upwards
done by the DS remedy or on the right
side done by an automated pipettor and
you see that the ic50 is determined by
either the d3 duo by the respective
other methods a nicely overlap so it
leads to equivalent results as a proof
of concept however what it leaves is
here is the plot of that same results
that you seen previously but now just
the standard deviations plotted and on
the right side you see plotted the
standard deviations of the order
pipettor and on the upward axis you see
the standard deviations that you achieve
the d3 Hamady so the median standard
deviation we get with an order pipettor
is around 0.18
whereas SEM with the different II we can
get a two fold improvement in standard
deviation so that means we have a better
reproducibility and a better data
quality everyone doing cell based assays
is well aware of the effect that you get
towards the edges on your plate so on
the outside wells and columns of your
rows and columns of your plate you often
have a higher evaporation or a different
thermal transfer and therefore the
results from these wells can deviate to
what you will see em in in the wells
that are more on the inner compartment
of the plate with the d3 MVD you can
randomize the entire plate layout just
with a click of a button so the upper
layout you would be fairly easily able
to achieve by manual pipetting but if
you look at the low one this just
becomes an impossible or very lengthy
task to to pipette and what that leads
to is we have here a comparison on the
left side between the non-randomized
layouts or the conventional layout and
we see a strong drop-off of the results
towards the higher concentrations where
on the right side if you look at a
randomized and dispensing we see that we
get a not much nicer distributions of
our data points and then therefore also
a much better data quality
and of course we also have something to
help you analyze it and so to D
randomize your data so there's a small
software tool which is called data merge
where you just copy paste your reader
data or your load your reader data and
combine it with the dispense report
which then puts your reader data
nicely back into order such that you
have no headaches in analyzing it also
how you could increase the quality of
data is if you look now at the left side
for example this is how some dilution
series are oftentimes performed so in
like triplicates of an eight point
dilution curve and you see how the data
points are spread out over the curve and
what the ic50 we determined ic50 is but
so the three times eight points these
twenty-four points you could also spread
out all along your like with the
concentration series which would lead to
a much nicer result however if you just
take only 16 points and spread them out
nicely over the whole concentration
range you see that you can save 1/3 of
your wealth and even there get nicer
data and better data quality so what
that leads is that it can help you to
save on your precious compounds and
reagents so this is real data from a
customer that serves internal customer
so just for your reference here on the
left side this refers to customer one to
four and they've been performing like
11-point titrations in triplicates or
eight point iteration it duplicates nine
point do it duplicates or eleven point
new triplicates
and in the next column you see how much
of a compound they have been using in
their traditional set up and it was
somewhere between 15 and 60 microliters
however if they switched over to the d
300 e they could save up to 90% of their
compound just by avoiding pre delusions
and by making more efficient use of
their si plain
so let me now show you a couple of the
software functions that we have in the
d300 II control software everybody
claims that their software is easy to
use and intuitive but the different MIDI
software allows you to copy-paste
already existing si setups that you have
in Excel right into the software and run
it from there so you will get started in
no time committed experiments what you
see here is also a color representation
of a couple of different possibilities
of dilution series of a randomized
dilution series also of a synergy
experiments or a drug drug interaction
study you can have duplicate the black
fill of the wells indicates that it has
been normalized or back filled with the
diluent to make sure that you're not
looking at an effect of games o or
whatever at low end you have in your or
whatever the low end you have a compound
dissolved in also if you had control
wells or have replicate of your
experiments okay let me show you a
couple of the software wizards and I'll
walk you through with a couple of
screenshots so let me start off with the
enzyme profile wizard so what this
allows you to easily set up complex
essays and it's a guided step-by-step
and through the wizard so in the first
step you will define what your enzyme is
what your substrate is and if you have
inhibitor said you want to test with a
substrate in the second step is you
define how you want to have it laid out
over the plate and then in the third
step is a just a control overview of how
your compound and your substrate and
your enzyme is distributed over your
assay plate so here just as an
enlargement so in in red you can see the
the enzyme in green the substrate and in
blue or in yellow you can see the
inhibitor which is added in different
concentrations to the enzyme profile
so like this it's easy to setup even
complex essays so be it
characterizations like enzyme
preparations Michaelis Menten kinetics
analysis so we have a substrate
titration with a fixed enzyme
concentration and/or also where you have
an inhibition like an inhibitor and
substrate and titration where you can
create lineweaver-burk plot so what we
see here and first of all in the
beginning I mentioned that we are doing
thermal inkjet technology so sometimes
people might be concerned that something
happens to their enzyme because of the
heating that occurs the very transient
one but here there is a PKA one
comparison both between the blue line
and with the d300 and the red relyin
with manual so a I'm basically a signal
concentration ratio and you see that in
both cases also for the map kinase up
here and that both the manually
dispensed one and also the one dispensed
by the divinity
there's no measurable activity loss due
to the use of the d300 what we see here
is HDAC enzyme kinetic activity si so
the enzyme kinetics were evaluated by
dispensing a fixed concentration of the
substrate and the saturation of the
enzyme and then the km value was despair
determined by separating the substrate
in the presence of a fixed concentration
of the enzyme and the d3m bead was used
to dispense both the enzyme and the
substrate in aqueous solution using
point one percent bridge 3582 both
stocks so we have to add a certain
amount of detergent so point one percent
of bridge 35 or triton x-100 or 0.3
percent of between 20 to our aqueous
stock solutions because they're very
small dispenser models we have otherwise
the aqueous solution because of the
surface tension would not even enter
these suspended nozzles so what that's
why we have to take off the surface
tension by adding a certain amount of
surfactant to it and this is customer
data and this is the voice this
the customer told us is that the km is
spot-on with our previous data however I
was able to get set up the essay in less
than 15 minutes compared to a whole
afternoon previously and that overall
the hdacs a turned out very well so this
is now a example of where the substrate
and an inhibitor was dispensed to the
enzyme so the D 300 was used to titrate
both the substrate in aqueous buffer
with this effective and an innovator
like a small molecule in in DMSO to
create lineweaver-burk plot to determine
the inhibition mode so and what you can
see here in the upper part is had a
mixed mode inhibition of an inhibitor or
a non competitive competitive inhibition
of the inhibitor that was to try
titrated with the SI and also here the
customer said that it was successful
with substrate may be dispensing
infinity experiments which are hard to
accomplish using other techniques and
that is extremely useful competitive
mechanism determination in enzymology um
with the so let me come to the next
result the PCI wizard because we see
that also in PCR setups customers want
to miniaturize the si more and more both
to save on the on the sample side and
also to save of course on the expensive
reagents like the master mix is used in
in the setup
so here's here screens over the PCI
wizard on the left side you define what
your master mixes are the middle column
is where you define your primer pairs
and then on the right side you define
which your samples are then the next
step you will add you will enter what
the volume is that you want to add of
your master mixes and the volume that
you want to add of your primers or you
can also add the concentration there and
then the volume to be added from the
sample and if you confirm that you get
to the next screen where you can define
a standard curve so which primers and
which standard or which sample you want
to have for your standard curve again
there how many titration levels you want
and what the spreading is so in that
case is the health log 1 by 2 dilution
and you can select how you want to have
the layout in the plate if you have one
habit by columns and where you want to
have your your standard curve dispensed
which is here in gray so what we show
here is also there we want to have a
comparison how well it compares to a
manual pipetting so in gray we have
manual results from a manually manually
set of experiment both in 12.5 Markley
the reaction volume of 5 microliters
reaction volume and again here you can
see that the the red and the or the
orange and the gray lines they nicely
are aligned so that means that there is
no difference whether you set your
experiment up with a d 300 e or manually
so there is no activity lost in your
math mix or some other effects to your
experiment however what this shows this
is a workflow from a customer won't go
through it into detail what this means
is they start off with zebrafish embryos
that they pull from similar test
conditions and they go through all the
steps of isolating the RNA then creating
the cDNA and then measure and determine
the amount of cDNA and use the cDNA then
to do a qPCR what they did with the d
300 years they eliminated a couple of
these steps so they went from the D from
the RNA right to the real-time PCR and
with that they could achieve tremendous
savings so um as we are talking about
animal embryo so they had in their
manual 25 Mike liter two-step process
they needed 8 embryos and they needed
only one embryo to do it with the d 300
e so definite time saving especially on
the RNA side they needed more than 2
micrograms for their manual setup
whereas they just needed point 1
microgram at point 0 1 microgram
with a d3 and VD from the super mix and
from the master mix they also needed
tremendous or a lot less and also from
the Primus they could save and the
entire workflow time was cut into health
so if you look in what that means by in
monetary Alice because of course the
dispensed heads they don't come for free
but even if you take into account and
the price of the dispenser and you see
that in the end is a total saving of up
to 30% M in toting materials and labor
so and five Michael is of course not the
smallest that he can achieve and in
volume we have here a comparison how
reactions set up in 5 microliters three
miraculous in two microliters all set up
by the G 300 e how they compare to each
other and so the blue bars are the two
microliter reactions the orange ones the
three microliter ones the gray bars two
five microliter reactions and the yellow
bars are where the math mix and the cDNA
was already pre-mixed and also set up in
a five microliter reaction and you see
that there is virtually no difference in
the result so it can easily scale down
your experiments to 2 microliters
reaction volume without any loss in
fidelity and without any problems with
your data quality so let me come to
another visit is the synergy wizard
which is very II which makes it very
easy to create and play designs for drug
drug interactions or synergy experiments
and it makes it all so easy to create
synergy sequences because of the
non-contact digital dispensing so and
how this energy visit how the synergy
wizard works as you define your one
target compound and then how this should
be combined with all the other
components that you have in your list so
in that case we have six drug drug
combinations out of the four and drugs
here on the left side
so this is again a real-world example
from a customer of ours and they are
assessing cancer samples and in one
experimental setup they look at 30
samples and each of these samples will
be distributed to two 96-well plates so
that makes a total of 60 plates which
makes it another total of 5760 well
secrete they treat the the samples with
a vehicle control and then they have ten
investigation compounds whereas seven
they do with individual dose responses
and then they have three dual drug
combinations and all of these are
seven-point those responses so this is
how such an experimental setup could
look like so we have the seven-point
dose responses so the seventh is always
the empty point and then we have the
three combinations which is basic are
tested against each other so here we
have a and B a and C and B against C so
everybody able to handle a pipette could
set something like this up but it will
take them quite some time and how much
time it takes even experience pipetters
we will see in the next slide so the
entire set-up time for including the
calculations and preparing the pre
delusions in manual works it was a three
and a half hours whereas with the d 300
e it was just 15 minutes and if you want
to see how easily this can be set up
with the d3 and ready just contact us
and we'll be happy to give you an online
demo of our software the treatment time
for the 60 plates so the single and the
combination editions and also the
vehicle backfill and this is no no joke
this really took 26 hours so it was
really three people working an entire
day to treat all these 60 plates
reliably with these compounds for the
defender he just took two and a half
hours of pipetting time so the entire
time savings is actually three in there
nearly three and a half full-time
equivalents also the color the amount of
the different compounds needed then was
reduced from 68 microwaves 436
microliters that might not seem a lot
but as we are talking
about investigational compounds they are
very precious so on the compound side
they could save 47% also another
underestimate if how much of the
hazardous chemical race you can save so
they had in totally 238 cubes 28 20
Mille of the tubes from from Dupree
delusions and whereas in the end they
just had the 10 investigational
compounds with seven seven microliters
in it wasted so that's a quite
significant waste reduction also the
accuracy improvement is like threefold
so that's a I think a clear statement
why to let complex F is probably
performed by some automation so to some
of the benefits that we have for the
Definity we have time savings that and
also a gain of confidence in accuracy we
can dispense any doubles in any well
directly into the SI plate so even with
cells in it or with your biochemical
reaction in it there's virtually no
cross contamination risk as we do
non-contact dispensing and dispensed
head are single-use and there's an
extended drug in range from microliters
to tens of pickle leaders and direct
iteration tipless you don't need any
dilution also simplified setup of PCR
reactions and enzyme profile experiments
become possible randomizing sample leads
to decreased edge effect decreased edge
effects and that's also just one click
of a button target lead dosing I didn't
talk about that one but we're happy to
show you that in the in the software
demo and also leads to less error in
standard in I see 50 values and accurate
drug drug titrations are made possible
and them simplified so also we have an
improved accuracy between verses manual
or automated pipetting based on the
delusions we have better hill slopes and
compared to manual or my defecating the
avoid localized concentration Peaks by
optional shaking of the destination
played during the dispensed
so during the dispense you can make the
DMV shake your plate such that the DMSO
or the diluent edit is dissolved in the
plate prior to the dispensing this and
the removal of the electrostatic effects
in the destination plate so they sent
the ionizer and you have cost savings
there is no plate or tip disposals for
the looseness necessary and not to
forget the convenience of for the
calculation of volumes or concentrations
and that guides user step-by-step
through the processes as you can see in
the video and we can we are happy to
send you references where customers
talked about in our chicken journal what
they did with it with the instrument and
so just contact us if you want to have
more details on these different articles
from our chicken journal and this just
leads me to end with one question which
is are you still hand pipetting or are
your bio printing already and with that
I want to hand over to hell very Berg
who will be talking about our fluent
automation solution Thank You Manuel so
my name is Hal Wehrenberg and I'm the
head of product management here at tea
can and I'm very excited to be telling
you about the other end the high
throughput portion of this talk the
laboratory automation solution that we
have named the fluent tea can actually
has a wide range of platforms the
freedom evo all the way up to the fluent
1080 I'm going to focus primarily on the
fluent itself right now because this is
the new one
this has got some of the latest features
that we have but it's built on the
pillars here of simplicity productivity
and confidence so let's jump right in
the fluent comes in three flavors there
is the small medium and large the fluent
four eighty seven eighty and ten eighty
if you will the difference is primarily
the sizes of these instruments so the
ten eighty itself is this one here this
is the big one it can be benchtop
or cabinet mounted it can have up to
three arms in any order and I'll talk
about the arms here in a moment it's got
the largest system in the highest debt
capacity so it's got 72 deck grids and
you'll see a little bit more what I mean
by deck grids and that allows us to have
up to 72 plate positions we can actually
have many many more plates than that on
the work table but I'll talk about that
as well
the fluid 780 this is the medium this
one is already showing you some of the
extensibility options we have so this
one is set up as an example of a high
throughput cell-based assay or even a
medium throughput cell-based assay on
the right hand side of the fluent we
have actually a carousel and a incubator
so the incubator is here the carousel is
up here and we're even hiding a washer
and a reader inside the optional cabinet
that we are on top of right here so this
is a really compact footprint even
though we can have up to three arms so
this does have our flexible channel arm
or multiple channel arm in a robotic
gripper arm the next one is the fluent
480 this is the twee' instrument the
cute one the small one the incredibly
compact and productive one for its
footprint this one can hold up to 30
micro plates 30 plate positions on the
work table one of the bigger differences
here is this with the it only can have
up to two arms so all of these systems
can have one arm or two arms the 780 and
the 1080 can have three arms pictured
here is the HEPA hood on top all of
these instruments we do have a HEPA hood
option so you can have clean air blown
onto your system so the fluent platform
actually is ready for all types of
assays when we launched this we really
wanted to make sure that we were
targeting very specific application
areas and we started with cell based
assays and so clean air was important
for that we've done drug discovery we're
in genomics we've actually done all
kinds of stuff with fluent now and it's
really ready for almost anything your
lab is where it wants to do the one
thing I haven't talked about which has
been present on every single one of
these pictures is actually the little
touch screen here so as you'll see the
hardware on the fluent is a very
sophisticated machine with lots of power
but we wanted to make sure that it was
always easy to use and I think a really
good example of this combination of
capacity speed and ease of use is
represented here by our fluent ID we're
going to play a video in just a moment
and what you will see is a quick loading
interface so the operator will start by
the touchscreen she will load the tubes
onto the work table and we reading at 96
tubes and three grids and when she's
done loading she presses continue and
we're ready for the assay to go so let's
go ahead and start that video
you
okay
so one of the sneaky things in that
video as well was right on the work
table we even have little lights to
indicate as the tubes are being read if
they were successfully read or not so it
takes no more time to put the tubes on
the work table than it does to also
identify every single one of them so
really when she pressed continue at the
end we were ready to start pipetting and
start the assay so you see here a really
simple interface with touch screen
guidance but you also see a highly
productive system that's very fast so
this is kind of the baked into the DNA
of everything fluent one of the next
things to show off here is the arms
themselves so you'll see here on the
work table we are six plates deep this
is part of what pulls off our own credit
incredible debt capacity the instrument
still fits through a standard doorways
so we can get into your lab but we also
have up to 32 tubes in a single position
really you're not going to find a system
for this footprint that has higher
capacity than the fluent the flexible
channel arm allows us to pipette from
any of those plates or any of those
tubes across the work table and we have
two flavors of the flexible channel arm
pictured here is the air flexible
channel arm and in a moment I'm going to
show you the other one and I challenge
you to spot the difference some of the
primary features of both of these arms
are that the tips can spread out to
reach into tubes the flexible channel
arm works primarily with disposable tips
we have a tip eject system so that we
can eject directly into a waste chute we
also have the ability to work with
nested tips so as I was saying before
that we have plate position 72 on the
1080 plate positions we can actually put
a stack of tips there so in a single
plate position we can have five layers
of nested tips each layer with 96 tips
and all of a sudden in a single segment
you can start holding thousands of tips
so that you make sure you're not you
have enough disposable tips to pipette
your samples and really protect against
cross-contamination
the other arm that we have is the liquid
flexible channel arm so I mentioned
these two arms look very similar the
liquid flexible channel arm also can use
disposable tips or it can have the
standard fixed tips which are washable
or we can mix and match on the liquid
flexible channel arm so we can have
fixed tips that are washable we can work
with disposable tips any combination you
need the flexible Channel arms are
capable pipetting down to half a micro
litre and one microliter and free
dispense up to a full mil the liquid
flexible channel arm can go as low as
200 nano liters when doing contact
dispensing with our low volume tips and
if you use our large syringes you can
pipe that all the way up to 5 ml so we
can really do a wide range of assays
here now just to point it out when
Manuel was talking he got to use the
word Pico leader we're not quite that
low as the HP enabled the technology but
this is really remarkable this dynamic
range on a single system is
market-leading these two arms can be put
together on a single system so on the 10
80s and the 7 80s you can have two
flexible channel arms with 16 channels
so if you were doing a lot of
cherry-picking work listing hit picking
whatever these works may be that you use
these arms can spread out across the
worktable aspirate all your wells of
interest and dispense it into an essay
writing plate at the end or if you are
doing something like normalization where
you needed each channel to be dealing
with independent different volumes
that's the other thing the flexible
channel arm does incredibly well as each
of these arms can spread out move up and
down in Z on its own do it's liquid
level detection and aspirate and pipette
an independently different volume all at
the same time so workflows like
normalization amazing and we can even do
traditional serial dilutions here as
well so if you needed to work that into
your assay we have no problem this arm
is great at that the next arm the
multiple channel arm this one has a nice
little video to show you this is the
flexible adapter exchange this arm has
384 channels in the head but the video
will show you is how quickly we can
switch between 384 tips and 96 tips
let's go ahead and start this video
you
you
okay
so that wasn't the video that was only
showing the fast exchange that video
showed you a little bit more I actually
stole my own thunder there that arm
showed off all three arms working in
parallel
including the robotic your forearm and
I'll get to that in a moment but what
you can see in this picture here is the
flexible adapter exchange so the MCA 384
has this adapter mounted it can swoop
down in a single motion switch to grab
these tips over here
we actually can deal with multiple
different sizes of tips and different
types of adapters we have the ability to
deal with fixed washable tips disposable
tips we can work in 96 tip formats 384
tip formats we have a pipetting range of
250 nano leaders all the way up to 500
microliters and but wait there's more we
have row and column functions this means
that not only do we deal with pipetting
entire plates from one to another if we
were doing reagent distribution of 96
wells all at once or copying a mother
plate to several daughter plates we also
can use this and pick up a single column
a single row and pipette serial
dilutions with this or pipette just the
controls in a single column this is a
really remarkably powerful arm the next
arm here which you also saw in that
video a moment ago is the robotic
gripper arm this arm here kind of speaks
for itself this allows us to do all
kinds of things we can switch fingers
and deal with plates or tubes or
actually reach through the work table
and load a centrifuge from the top this
arm is my personal favorite arm actually
and it doesn't doesn't need many slides
to describe exactly what it can do I
think I actually might want to show that
video one more time here of all three
arms working together and just point out
one or two more things for you to show
like to take a look at as we do this the
robotic gripper arm on the right will be
picking up fingers and this is kind of
like a a dissolution workflow a couple
steps in the dissolution workflow you'll
see the robotic gripper
pick up fingers manipulated to scan it
lay it bring it back and then we will
pipette system fluid into it with our
liquid film flexible channel arm and
then the MCA arm will be adding dill you
into the plate all at once and if you
watch closely for the MCA you will see
it come forward and pick up a head
adapter with all 96 tips mounted at once
so let's go ahead and take one more look
at that video and you'll see all of this
together
you
okay thank you for indulging me and
letting you show that video twice the
robotic gripper arm just to say it out
loud doesn't have to use the finger
exchange option that is we also have the
ability to deal with fixed fingers that
are permanently mounted to the head so
if you only need to use one of those
types of fingers we would just screw
that on and that's all you would have
the system is not only really flexible
in terms of what the arms can do it
actually has a really flexible work
table concept here what you see here in
this picture is the operator actually
lifting a worktable segment out so each
one of these points can be changed on
the work table in this picture with all
the arms altogether there's some places
for plates there's some places for tubes
there's even a hole right in the middle
of the work table that we accomplished
by removing one of the carriers
this makes the vertical integration on a
fluent phenomenally easy and actually
really cheap in comparison to
competitive options out there this work
table does have a patent on it we call
it our dynamic deck and it makes the
system just wildly flexible so if you if
your needs change in 12 months and you
need to do different assays with
different carriers we can actually do
that with this work table very easily so
protection that investment very strongly
one of our longtime fluent customers
actually was telling me recently that
the flexibility of the system is
actually more important to him than the
speed and the easy usability he said the
flexibility of the system is what allows
him to keep the assays that he wants to
do in-house because he can be faster and
adapting his work clothes than it would
be to try and have a CRO take on some of
his workflows or anything like that the
flexibility ensures that he has
redundancy between his systems and that
when he needs to bring on a new assay he
can do it very fast so the dynamic work
table is also very very configurable so
you have different types of arms you can
mount these arms all together on the
same system you can change the work
table however you need and the system
can become very sophisticated very
quickly all of that said we thought it
was wildly important to keep it simple
we wanted to make sure that
the forefront of this entire system this
entire platform was the operator so we
have an intuitive touch interface
I hate when software people give you a
pitch about intuitive software but I
think it's true for us so I decided why
not we'll put the word on the screen
take a look at these screens here I
don't have to tell you anything for you
to understand what to do on any of these
screens and actually just to point it
out on the right hand side that's
completely customizable content as well
you can show pictures and give text to
your operators right on that touch
screen customized to every single run
you can take out a picture your cell
phone take out a picture and put it on
here I like to tell my sales guys this
is easier and faster to setup in a
PowerPoint slide so this interface is
phenomenally important it's the type of
thing the operators will be using every
single day again more examples that I
don't need to explain to you you can
figure out which one is the login screen
you can figure out which one is the Go
button to start the run in the middle at
the bottom that's a basic user prompts
these are all default screens there's no
extra programming to build any of this
this is what comes with fluent control
now if you are a bit of a software geek
we actually give a lot of power here for
you to customize the content on the
touch screen as well you can take user
input so you can create custom controls
you can do a lot of stuff in this but by
default really easy to put up your own
pictures any user prompts that comes up
during the run where the system needs an
operator to interact that will come up
in plain text it will be easy to click
buttons truly an intuitive interface it
reduces the training for new operators
and it makes it easier for you to have
multiple operators working on the same
system because as they are running new
assays they have a familiar interface
that doesn't require explanation that
guides them through their runs now
behind that is a configuration software
package designed for creating the work
tables and for programming some steps
will give you a quick demonstration of
it here with another video so I'd like
to get that started now
the bottom and I'll click on that so
that I can see the list of lab where
that I'm allowed to bring out will place
a 96-well plate here but this could be
any lab where and now I'll bring out the
first of our smart command a reagent
distribution command I can use this to
transfer say 100 microliters from a
trough on the work table which I select
by just a simple click and then I select
which well so I could also be pipetting
from tubes for example I select the lab
where and I can even reserve wells in
this target lab where for things like
controls or standard curves I don't have
to pipette the entire plate we also have
parameters like the number of samples
that we can use to impact what happens
at runtime and that's it I press go I
get a prompt to save and fluent control
is already preparing the script we're
actually controlling an instrument now
the reagent distribution command
generates this script for me on the fly
based on the parameters I gave it at at
at time and it can be different based on
whatever user types in we see the trough
that were pipetting from it's generating
that first set of dispense those four
wells and then another dispensed but at
eight wells and it's going to go through
and fill that full plate for me but if I
had actually had a value in that samples
field say I had the number 12 it would
only do those first two dispense steps
and therefore every single run can be
different and dynamically based on the
number of samples I'm processing and
it's just one script command it doesn't
have to be different we also have smart
commands for things like the sample
transfer so with the flexible channel
arm I can pet pet from hundreds of tubes
to multiple plates all of the single
script line I hope that this one minute
was enough to show you why we are so
excited about this command and we hope
you are too
so that was really just to try and give
you a taste of what it's like to
configure new assays in the software and
show you some of the commands at your
disposal that make everyday tasks really
easy to do but your operators again will
be working with that touchscreen fluent
control is easy and it's powerful so for
those of you who are a bit software
geeks and those of us who are have no
problem identifying as that you know
that it's important to be able to do
what your assay needs and fluent control
does not actually strip back any of the
power if the hardware can do what do
what you need it to the software can
control it the system is also something
that we call teach free what teach free
means is the accuracy and precision of
the hardware is so good and our patented
dynamic deck it has so few tolerances
and our definitions of software are so
good it means when you do the IQ okay
when we bring an instrument into your
lab we test and make sure the arms are
correctly aligned but then you can put
our default carriers on your work table
and you can start by petting it at 348
384 well plate without even checking the
definitions ahead of time it's really an
amazing system makes it very easy to
transfer scripts from one instrument to
another and it makes it very fast to set
up new robots in your lab the other
thing that is very important for us is
that anyone can modify an assay so if
you give me three bullet points to
summarize know and control it's a
touch-based operator interface that
needs no explanation it's just another
way to call it intuitive tea tree
building I teach free makes building and
sharing assays robust and fast and
finally you saw the software in action
you know what I mean when I say anyone
can create or modify an assay when you
walk back up your system six months
later you just want to tweak something
you want to change the volume of the
reagent distribution or any of that it's
going to be right there and easy for you
to do that software is what controls the
laboratory automation solution known as
the fluent it's going to help you do
more in less time these tasks specific
arms can work in parallel each arm is
very fast in its own right but by
working in parallel we can get even more
faster this is an example here of a
nucleic acid purification setup for
those of you who know that workflow
you'll notice some magnetic separators
in the front 2d barcode scanner in the
back are an armed pipette from troughs
to plates to replicate from plates we've
got all kinds of stuff on that system
doing more in less time so incredible
debt capacity six plates deep nested
tips on the right-hand side of this
picture over here so we actually have
thousands of tips for the flexible
channel arm and integration of devices
through the work table so here is a top
loaded centrifuge right underneath the
work table getting loaded by the robotic
gripper I'm taking up no more space in
your lab the arms are all dynamic they
can switch their functions they can
change tools on-the-fly whatever your si
needs we can go and grab the tool and
move on this also lets you react to new
assays as the challenges and demands in
your lab are adapting the robot can grow
with you all of the arms are field
upgradeable all of the carriers are
field upgradeable about the only thing
that's not field upgradeable is
switching from a 480 to a 1080 but of
course will happily give you a second
fluent whenever you want one making it
easy for operators so empowering your
operators to get more tasks done daily
by reducing the training and by guiding
them through every assay step as they go
and making that interface of such a
sophisticated instrument easy to handle
you can actually have more operators
doing more work on such a powerful
platform and again the patented dynamic
Dex switching on-demand to whatever your
assays need and finally we're designed
for today and ready for tomorrow you can
add new options we integrate all kinds
of third-party devices the worktable
itself is very flexible the 3d simulator
and the bottom is going to let you also
even without monopolizing your
instrument once you get it in high
productive use you can actually program
and check and look at what a new si
would run like see what those runtimes
are and get a feel for how it works on
your own computer and then when you have
the new instrument in your lab teach
free means you can export and import and
have it run on the new instrument and
record
time I think that's everything we wanted
to show I we are open for a few
questions here Manuel is still sitting
next to me so for those of you who have
d300 questions he is around on your
phone thank you
yeah I was in sa thank you so much for
that informative presentation gentlemen
and let's go ahead and get right into
those questions and input from our
audience and just a reminder for all
audience members who are would like to
communicate with us today questions can
be submitted via the Q&A button at the
end and the lower the left if we are
unable to get to those questions due to
time constraints Pell and manuals we'll
reach out via email so let's start with
our first set of questions from our
audience members looks like the first
one is for you health
what kind of barcode reading does fluent
support sure so we have lots of options
on barcode readers as you probably would
guess my sir is going to be we actually
can integrate a barcode scanner right
onto a robotic gripper arm we can also
work with a standalone barcode scanners
on the work table and we can pick up
plates and bring them to 2d barcode
scanners or do 1d barcodes on the sides
we support all the major formats of 1d
barcodes we also integrate with
third-party devices so in the nucleic
acid system there was actually as is 2d
barcode scanner hiding in the back and
our fluent ID scanner is a 1d barcode
scanner but this is a very open field if
you have a need we can probably address
it I've encouraged you to talk directly
to us or of one of our sales engineers
wonderful thank you and let's go ahead
and take another question from our
audience for you to hell on if
everything is teach free what about
carriers or labware uh-huh I'm so like
customizing carriers in lab where the
what I showed here was our default
carriers but we actually are really good
at handling customized lab where the
system even has something I didn't show
it at all here due to time called zero-g
mode where you can move the arms by hand
and the motors actually make it feel
like it's zero gravity because we
counterbalance the weight of the arms
and we leave the encoders on so we know
where the arm is to within 1/10 of a
millimeter and we can use that to
position devices or to teach lab where
custom lab or custom carriers so fully
customizable system our defaults are
grading tea tree but if you need to
teach we make that pretty easy as well
thank you so much
actually we have one more question
directed for you does fluent control
have an API yes so thank you software
key whoever you are
API is an advanced programming interface
and yes local control has an API it's a
fairly simple one but you can use it to
remotely start scripts and interact with
the system and variables there's a an
example Excel spreadsheet delivered with
fluid control that shows off this
functionality and if you're curious I
would actually be happy to personally
give a demo at some point in the future
tell before we switch over to some of
these questions where Manuel did you
want to provide the audience with any
closing remarks no other than simply
saying thank you so much for giving us
both a chance to show off our systems
I've been working with the club for six
years and three of them with customers
in the field and I've just been
delighted with how much we've
accomplished so far and I look forward
to working with any of you who are
meeting the fluent for the first time so
thank you for your time and that will
pass over to Manuel now thank you so
much all right it looks like a few
wonderful questions here from the
audience for you Manuel our first one is
are the cassette single use only yes
they are I mentioned that during the
presentation already as we are talking
about volumes down to 211 Pico liters we
have to make sure that whenever a new
fluid is put into a dispenser that it
basically meet a new dispenser because
if there is all fluids in it there might
be a precipitation or there might be
crystals and we would not be able to
guarantee the performance down to that
volume so that's why the cassette
sourcing leaves only
okay thank you so much and here's
another one are there problems with
putting surfactants into the stock
solution um so this is probably from a
person concerned about cell based assays
so what we found is that it depends on
the cell type which surfactant use
however if there is only 0.1% of
surfactant needed in the stock solution
and we are distributing very low volumes
into the SA plate the concentration is
in the SA plate is somewhere below 0.001
percent however if you are working with
the cell base si we'd encourage you to
try out different surfactants and do a
titration just with this effect and to
see whether your cells reacted but so
far we haven't seen any problems with
that great thank you so much we have one
more audience question how do you I
verified if my compound was really
dispensed with these small volumes okay
that's a very good one of course we
you're hardly able to see 11 or 13 Pico
liters so that what it makes what makes
it very hard to verify it however in the
manufacturing process so everybody knows
that from from his inkjet printer so the
the the ink of the dispense heads they
are made in the same factory where all
the other HP print print heads are made
and before a print dispenser is inserted
into a cassette each of them is
individually checked so that it's
working as intended so by adding the
fluid into the dispense ed you can
actually be sure that this is a working
dispensed head because it has been
tested before is what before it was
entered and then similar to what happens
in your desktop printer before it starts
printing there's also AM a priming step
on going and such that the the dispenser
is probably filled but if the if you're
concerned about that and we're happy
to give you a demo and they can see you
from you can see for yourself if that
matches your expectations and we are
happy to do so thank you very much
Manuel I give hell an opportunity to
provide some closing remarks did you
want to add a few things as well sure
thank you for having us there and I look
forward to hopefully talking to a lot of
you about the DQ MBD great thank you
gentlemen thank you so much again for
your informative presentation we want to
also thank lab roots for providing this
wonderful educational webcast and t-con
for making it possible today's webcast
will be available for on-demand until
August 2017 keep an eye out for an email
from lab reach alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay
we encourage you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
next time goodbye now